Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today, we're your hosts
of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us!
Have you enjoyed
the past two days...
of Advent debuts?
It's been a busy two days for
hololive English -Advent-members
like us, and Biboo, and
Shiori, and Nerissa, but...
Did you enjoy them?
Did you watch them?
Did you enjoy the two
days of Advent debuts?
- How was it?
How's it been?
We hope you enjoyed them!
Did you find a new oshi, maybe?
It's always good
to get new favorites.
Well...
Today is a very
special day because
this is the pilot episode
of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Does it seem kind of mysterious?
Is it mysterious?
Well, maybe a happy mysterious, but... Yes.
FUWAMOCO Morning is not that mysterious.
It's our special live program held
every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Surprise!
It's a short format
morning show.
I guess it might be
a late night show.
Which one is it for
you? What time is it?
Is it a morning show?
Is it a late night show?
- Or is it a...
- Should we change the name?
Yeah, which one?
Morning?
- Morning?
- Afternoon?
Late night, late night.
FUWAMOCO Morning in your heart.
But if it's like "FUWAMOCO Night
Time", that's a different kind of show, no?
FUWAMOCO in your heart.
Morning in your heart, but
also FUWAMOCO in your heart.
FUWAMOCO Morning,
what we aim to do is we aim to
bring a smile to your face and help
you start your day off on the right paw.
You might have noticed
with our schedule, but y'know
We're really hoping to start
our day together with you.
And together.
You know, playing fun games
and doing other different things.
And that way we can all have a really
happy, healthy life routine all together.
Yeah, it's important.
We need you Ruffians
in good shape, okay?
You gotta stay tip-top healthy.
You have to be the
hot dog of every day.
Right?
Is that okay?
You're good with
being healthy, right?
Well, maybe it might happen
whether you like it or not.
Anyways, we'd be really honored if
you could spend time with us like this.
- And Japanese too!
- Yeah, you're right!
Before we forget!
FUWAMOCO Morning is...
FUWAMOCO Morning is a
regular morning variety show.
- Yeah, it is.
- Yes.
I know it's a bit late for
everyone in Japan, but
This show's goal is to
help you start your day off
With a smile.
- That's the goal!
- Healthy!
But yeah, today's
just the pilot episode.
But we really hope that
FUWAMOCO Morning can be
A really warm, cozy show
that we can all enjoy together.
Maybe as you roll out of bed,
or maybe on your way to work?
Or you're like "ahh,
today's no good, dame da."
Then maybe we can put on FUWAMOCO Morning
and be like "okay, I'll get out of bed."
That would make us really happy.
But yeah, since
today's the pilot episode,
It's a bit different.
It's episode 0, right?
Episode 0.
Pilot episodes never really end
up to be, like, the actual show, right?
- Well, we'll all have to find out!
- Yeah, right?
It's gonna be a journey.
- What does FUWAMOCO Morning become?
- Right?
- It's still a mystery to us, too.
- Yeah.
I think it's good like that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But, first and foremost,
we have one thing.
We wanted to say...
Big, big thank you!
De-den!
We've reached 300,000 Ruffians!
Can you believe it?
We've reached 300,000 Ruffians! It's all
thanks to everyone! Thank you very much!
- Thank you!
I don't really,
like, understand.
We're absolutely blown away.
It's actually kind
of dizzying for me.
Thank you very much!
Thank you so much
for all your support!
And of course we're really
thankful to our senpai's hard work
Building up hololive to make it
the amazing place that it is today.
Even though today
is... Does it still count?
It's our first day as brand new
members of hololive English.
We would really like to
do the same, you know.
To make hololive an even
more amazing and even
more warm place for
our future kouhai, too.
Isn't it a bit early
to be thinking that?
It's a little bit early, but... It's
important, you know? It's important, so...
It'd make us really happy if you continue to
let everyone know about all of us at Advent.
And if you could continue to spread
your love of hololive everywhere you go.
Maybe even FUWAMOCO
could be included in that too, huh?
Is that okay?
- Thank you for all the congrats!
- You know?
I saw on Twitter some Ruffians
already have an oshi mark.
Yeah, I saw it
too! I saw it too!
- Thank you so much!
- Thank you!
We're very happy
puppies right now.
Once Twitter starts to be nice to us
again, we'll be able to look at more stuff.
So it's been a bit difficult for us,
but we want to see lots of stuff.
I noticed I made a spelling, a silly
typo, in actually a couple tweets.
And I wanted to retweet it,
but then I got embarrassed.
I haven't really been
able to look at the tweet.
Did you notice it?
You didn't notice, right?
Please don't notice.
Please don't notice, okay?
You know, I even asked Fuwawa to
copy what she was gonna post, but
Moco-chan looked at it
and she said it was okay.
I was sleepy.
You didn't notice, okay.
I'll do better.
But you know, deleting
tweets? That's no good.
You can't delete it.
Even if you have a typo.
What? We're gonna make another big
mistake and then delete our tweets today.
Just because we said it.
Please. Twitter, be nice to us.
My fingers... Which typo?
No, don't look, okay?
Don't look, don't
look, don't look.
Now they're gonna be watching
our tweets and be like "Ooh..."
We just...
- No more typos, okay, Moco-chan?
- We did it to ourselves.
Well, the next thing... You might have
noticed we had a bit of a surprise for you.
De-den!
Kaibutsu!
Did you hear it?
Did you watch it?
Our first cover song.
You didn't miss it, right?
It was released at the very end.
We kind of forgot!
Yeah. Kaibutsu by YOASOBI-san.
Yeah, we covered
Kaibutsu by YOASOBI-san.
Moco-chan just said that.
- But, it's... It's...
- Really happy.
What did you think
of it? "It's really good"?
- You like it?
- Thank you for listening to it!
"Cover is fire!" Thank you!
It made us really happy because, you know,
it's our first cover song with FUWAMOCO.
And, you know, we actually, we don't
really have that much experience recording.
- We just like to howl.
- We just howl.
And that's it.
Yeah. You don't record the
howling, you just howl, right?
You just howl and
then you're done.
So, it's really special to
us to have a recording that
not only we can listen,
but you can listen to too.
And, you know, Kaibutsu.
We chose it for a
very special reason.
Moco-chan, do you
want to talk about it more?
Well, I feel like recently I've
had lots of just like, lightning.
- Hirameki?
- Hirameki, like, it just strikes me.
That's what Kaibutsu was.
It was like "yoshi yaro"!
I'm gonna do it! Kaibutsu!
At first I was
like "Aah, uhm..."
But then after
reading the lyrics,
It really really resonated
within us, you know?
The meaning of the lyrics for
songs is always really important to us
So we'd like you to
check them out if you can.
The reason why we covered
Kaibutsu this time was
Because the lyrics really
resonated with our hearts. Right?
That's the reason we did it.
We sang that.
- It was a new challenge.
- Yeah, it was.
- It was a new challenge recording Kaibutsu.
- Yeah, there's so many harmonies.
Right? Usually when we howl
together it's just like "BAU BAU!"
And maybe like a
little bit "BAU BAU!"
Moco-chan, you'd do the BAU BAU.
Right?
- That's accurate.
- Right?
We're a bit nervous, but...
Hamahiro-san did such a
good job with the mix magic.
And Hae-san
with the illustration.
Omika-san, beautiful video!
You checked it out, right?
Did you notice all the little
things? All the cool things?
Go find them.
If you watched it once, maybe it's time to
go watch it twice after FUWAMOCO Morning.
Right?
But it was a really,
really fun experience.
We're looking forward
to hopefully doing more.
We know we talked about the
lyrics being really important to us.
But maybe if you don't
understand Japanese,
it might be difficult to
understand the meaning,
And that's why we did an English
translation ourselves: FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO did
the English translation.
- It's not quite ready yet, though.
- Not quite yet.
So we're hoping that it'll be up
soon, but we'll let you know, okay?
Please look forward to it!
But still watch it now, and then you
can watch it once they're done, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can turn off all the lights,
Make it fullscreen and watch
it like you're in a movie theater.
Really loud, right?
Make the neighbors angry.
That's the recommendation.
Please watch it, okay?
As for one thing... I thought
maybe we should address...
- It's still our first day, but...
- This.
There's a misunderstanding!
Did you know?
- bau bau bau...
- This.
Apparently...
There's a rumor. A
misunderstanding.
I was framed!
I was framed.
During the collab.
Both Calli-senpai and A-chan thought
that Fuwawa said something that was wrong.
No! I didn't say anything bad!
I'm not the first Advent
member to say a bad word!
No, no, no, no.
Ruffians, you're not thinking
that I really said that, right?
You know I'm not that
kind of person, right?
We aren't.
Us and Biboo are
not that type of person.
I don't know about Nerissa and
Shiori, but... Not us and Biboo.
You know, it happened when I
was explaining, you know, how...
We got into The
Cell and everything.
And I said "we got locked up!"
But they thought
it was "fluffed up."
Moco-chan, you're gonna
say it straight like that?
But a bit different than that.
A bit different than that!
I think A-chan and Calli-senpai, maybe
they need to get their ears adjusted.
Their minds out of the gutter.
Ruffians, you too!
You too if you thought that.
You have to believe us, okay?
"I believe them." Thank you!
Thank you for believing.
You understand that?
I am not the first member
of Advent to say anything.
And I will never be the last...
The last member to say...
I will never be a member that
says something bad like that.
- Got it? Understood?
- Nerissa and Shiori? I'm not too sure.
Now that we all
understand that... De-den!
We wanted to talk
about the debut goods!
The debut goods!
Have you checked them out?
OK, OK. I know maybe we're like:
"Of course FUWAMOCO would want
to talk about the debut goods," right?
Somebody probably told them.
- Not that.
- No.
We're really excited.
Do you understand
how amazing this is?
Do you understand?
- You already bought them! Ooh! Thank you!
- Thank you!
Well, the reason why we
wanted to talk about them is...
You know, for FUWAMOCO,
this is really big.
This is really exciting!
I think for a lot of people,
they sort of think that like,
Goods are given and it's
just gonna happen, right?
- But it's not!
- No, it's not!
So, we're really,
really excited.
We hope you are too.
We hope you check
them out, you know.
There's the acrylic
stands, the acrylic panels.
There's acrylic laminates.
I am really excited about those.
There's the stained glass.
The strap! The
stained glass strap!
And of course the voices.
The voice too. Yes,
the pre-escape voices.
Really, really fun to
be able to record it.
- Ah, we forgot Japanese.
- We did forget!
Everyone in Japan: did you guys
check out our Advent merch?
- Our debut merch is on sale, y'know?
- It's on sale!
I can't stop getting excited.
Y'know, FUWAMOCO...
The reason we wanted to
talk about our merch today
is because we think
it's really important to us.
Wow!
- "Wow," isn't it?
- "Wow" indeed!
And because merch is
not a given, of course,
We're really happy.
We'd be glad if you
could check it out.
Please check it out, OK?
Yeah, we didn't know.
We haven't decided how many goods,
how many merch sets
- we're supposed to buy.
- 'Cause you're supposed to buy 3.
Three?! That's the
otaku rule, right?
I can't remember, I
just remember three.
One to, like, love?
One for saving.
And what was the other one?
To love again when the
other one gets loved up?
- Maybe.
- Maybe?
But it's okay, you can
buy more than three too.
An army.
- An army of FUWAMOCO!
- Y'know? That is fun though.
I do have a little army too.
It's good to have collections
that make you happy, you know?
Being surrounded by
the ones you love most.
I hope you check it out,
especially the pre-escape voice.
That was really... I wasn't
sure if I was doing things right.
- It was fun, but it was a bit scary.
- Yeah.
We're not gonna spoil anything,
so you'll have to give it a listen.
But let us know what
you thought of it, okay?
I'm sure your heart will be beating
just as fast as ours were, so...
Ah, you got it?
- Ah, thank you!
- Please listen, please listen!
Oh, you bought
it, too? Thank you!
Well, we also, it wasn't just the
pre-escape voice that we recorded,
But we also did
the starting voice!
You might have seen them because
All the other hololive members
have been releasing them, but
It's kind of nice because
with the start of Advent
It's also the start of
our starting voices.
We all, all of the other members
recorded in both English and Japanese.
Both of them.
And I know, for us, like...
Not June. July.
It's June. It's June, June,
June, July! July, July!
It's July.
But you know, for Shiori, and for
Bijou, and for Nerissa, it wasn't...
It wasn't a walk in the park.
No, it wasn't a walk in the park
for them to record it in Japanese.
So, you know, we all
helped out each other.
And we had a
little bit of a listen.
And it's really, really cute.
We recommend it a lot.
Please check them
out as well, okay?
There's a lot of
different variations.
Cute morning voices,
sleepy voices, grumpy voices.
Especially Moco-chan's
grumpy voice.
But you never know what
it's going to quite be like, so...
"I can't wait to listen."
???
Please listen to
our starting voices.
They're both in
English and Japanese.
All the Advent members did
it, so please check them out.
This is very important information
for FUWAMOCO Morning.
We wanted to let you know that
Starting next time there will be a
new corner for FUWAMOCO Morning!
We'd like to introduce two new
segments called Doggie of the Day.
We'll start with the first one.
The next FUWAMOCO Morning
will have two new segments.
The first one is called
Doggie of the Day.
There's a corner called Doggie of
the Day, and we're hoping that
You'll send us your best puppers for us to
introduce and brighten everyone's day.
We've already seen
some very bestest friends.
They're so cute.
They've been being sent in to help
FUWAMOCO, and it's been very, very helpful.
We're very happy to see it, but
We'd also like to nominate them with the
FUWAMOCO Morning...
- The #FWMCMORNING hashtag.
- It's in the title.
So, you know, we
can introduce them.
On that topic.
You tweeted.
Hashtag FUWAMOCO Morning, right?
Maybe they have you.
Ruffians!
Have you?
It's okay if you don't know
what to tweet, you know.
There's always BAU BAU.
So...
Go and tweet.
BAU BAU!
#FWMCMORNING.
- Or a good pupper.
- Oh, good pupper. Yeah, you know.
But yes, we'll be waiting to see
your furry and fuzzy dog friends.
And fluffy.
- Furry and fluffy.
- Yeah.
Ah, I forgot "fluffy", didn't I?
But not just that, we also have the
Today I Went for a Walk segment.
It's not just the Doggie
of the Day segment.
- It's like "Today's Walk".
- Today I Went for a Walk.
- We're doing it right.
- Yes, we are.
Yeah, there's a
segment like that.
Yes, so for Today
I Went for a Walk.
We'd like to ask you to
maybe submit a picture.
- If you want.
- Yeah, if you want.
And a small report when you go out for a
walk using the #FWMCMORNING.
Yeah, FUWAMOCO Morning.
You know how much we
like to go for walks, right?
Walks are so good.
So we thought that it would make
us really happy if we could hear
about all the wonderful little
adventures that you'd be going on.
Usually we like to take
little photos and stuff like that
to remember like "oh, this
happened today" and stuff.
- Right?
- So we thought that
It'd make you happy
too if you did that.
You know, like...
- "Today's flowers are really pretty!"
- Right?
Or you saw something
like "haha, that's silly!"
Those kind of things.
But only if you're comfortable.
Yeah, you could,
like, share a photo.
Yeah, flowers, nature.
Those kind of things.
Anything that made you smile.
If it made you smile, then
it'll definitely make us smile.
So please make sure you add the
hashtag #FWMCMORNING to your tweet.
And if you could include
a sentence or two just
about how your walk was,
maybe how it made you feel.
Even if it's like a rainy day.
Yeah, you know, just what
made today's walk extra special.
- Right?
- Yeah.
We'll be looking forward
to your stories of
Getting outside, stretching the
puppers, getting some fresh air.
Those kind of things.
Can you do that?
We'll be waiting, okay?
We'll be waiting, so
make sure you do it.
- We also need more help.
- We need more help.
We're a little bit
needy sometimes.
Hopefully that's okay, but...
Yes!
On tomorrow!
On tomorrow at 6pm PT, 9pm ET,
1am GMT, and 10am JST.
From 10am Japan time.
We have our first Q&A stream!
We're gonna be doing it!
Tomorrow!
Yes, tomorrow!
So we'd like you to
ask, we've seen a lot of
questions, a lot of really
good questions so far.
But I'm sure you probably
have still lots of questions.
So if you have any, please send
them to us with the hashtag, helpFWMC.
And we'll pick out as
many as we can, okay?
It's right there on the screen.
Yeah, tomorrow, tomorrow!
Is it that shocking?
Well, if you can think of a
question before tomorrow, right?
There's a lot, a lot of
questions I think you could think of.
You know, like, what's it like
being twin demon dog sisters?
What's life like together?
What's Pero like?
You know, those
kind of things, right?
So, we're gonna be looking
forward to your questions, okay?
But is tomorrow a thing?
I don't get it.
Tomorrow!
I'm happy, you're
happy about it.
I see lots of good questions.
There's a lot of good questions.
I'd make us happy if you'd tweet
them with the hashtag #helpFWMC.
- That's cute in Japanese. "Help FUWAMOCO"
- Help FUWAMOCO, yeah!
Help me!
We need a lot of help.
But maybe it's a bit
more fun now, right?
But that's not all!
After FUWAMOCO Morning today,
later in the evening we have VLOG!
Tonight!
Even better than tomorrow.
Yeah, tonight at 6PM PT, 9PM ET,
1AM GMT, and 10AM JST.
- In Japan time, 5am...
- 10am.
- You're right, 10am.
- Not 5am, 10am.
Yes, yes, yes.
We'll be playing our
first game, Phogs.
We've become a
cutie hot dog phog.
We've never played it
before, but it looks very
cute and colorful, and
we make cute noises.
Yeah, BAU BAU! BAU BAU!
Yeah, it's tonight!
Even closer.
We're really
looking forward to it.
I feel like it's been such a long time since
I played a game together with you, Moco-chan.
It'll be very relaxing.
I think.
- Really?
- I think.
We're not gonna,
like, fight or argue?
I wanna go this way!
I wanna go that way!
If we wanna go one way
later, we can just do that later.
It's not that hard.
You'll have to come and check
it out to see how things go, okay?
I think this is maybe the only cute
game on our schedule this week.
Yeah. All of them are
sort of scary or tough.
Yeah, but... It'll be okay because
you'll be there with us, right, Ruffians?
Right!
You'll join us, right?
Right?
Right!
Well... Before...
Before we get going, we'd like to share our
schedule and just have another little peek.
One last time.
It's a bit tiny, but if you'd
like to see it a bit bigger,
You can check out
our Twitter as well.
We have some very exciting things
coming up and we'd really like you to
make sure that you come and walk out
at our FUWAMOCO Rock n' Rawr Party!
On Saturday?
- Saturday?
- Yeah.
- On Sunday in Japan... Sunday, right?
- Yeah, that's right.
We'll have our first ever karaoke stream.
We'll have our karaoke Rock n' Rawr Party.
It's kind of like "rokku an
rouru," right? Just like that.
It's got an interesting name.
We'd be glad if you could join us.
- We like singing, after all.
- Let's sing together!
Please come and please
sing along with us, OK?
- We're really excited.
- Yeah.
There's a lot of good
music, a lot of songs.
- Good songs are good!
- Good songs are good, you know?
Especially anime songs too.
We hope you'll be there!
We also have a
very, very mysterious
Surprise stream on Sunday.
So it's a question,
question, question.
- What could it be?
- We don't know.
- Question, question, question.
And also we have
Advent collab playing.
- Left 4 Dead 2.
We need your
strength, so please.
Please.
Please, please.
But I'm really looking
forward to it though.
Because even though it's
kind of scary, you know,
Shiori and Bijou and Nerissa
will be there, so it'll be okay, right?
Right.
Well, before we say
BAU BAU for now,
We'd actually like to shout out to
some of our Extra Special Ruffians today.
Is that okay?
Okay?
- Say BAU BAU now!
- BAU BAU! OK?
BAU BAU!
Alex!
It's so fast I can't read it!
Nisha!
BAU BAU!
Ryo-san!
[???] BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there,
we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!